[Applauso]
grazie
proviamo a fare anche senza slide
vediamo se riesco a trasmettervi tutte a
parole la prima slide era la copertina
di chè significa quindi prova a
prendermi i film di steven spielberg
banalmente la storia è quella di appunto
frank abagnale che riesce a scappare da
falsario quindi falsare truffatore e
scappa per anni e nessuno riesce mai a
prenderlo qual è questa cosa voglio dire
con questa metafora che il vino oggi per
i prossimi quindici minuti sarà il
nostro frank abagnale noi cercheremo di
capire come riusciamo come riusciremo a
prenderlo nel prossimo futuro
partiamo subito con una buona e una
cattiva notizia buona notizia è che oggi
di vino ne parliamo ne parliamo 15
minuti ma poi alla fine di tutto non so
se avranno detto ma ci sarà un rinfresco
lino queste questa è una cosa positiva
la seconda cosa invece un pochino più
meno positiva qualeche che purtroppo
statisticamente 9 su 10 di noi non
capiranno abbastanza di vino per poterne
goderne appieno perché questo perché in
realtà il vino è un prodotto molto
complesso è complesso perché ci sono
tante sfaccettature che ben rendono la
distanza tra i consumatori normali il
prodotto molto lunga
prima tra tutte è quella degli esperti
in realtà tanti gli aspetti del vino che
una cosa interessante sono vengono dalla
storia sono rimasti immutati per oltre
milani pensate che il primo esperta
progetto sommelier risale ai greci
quindi 3.000 anni fa e poi si è voluto
fino ad arrivare una figura quasi
mitologica al tempo dei romani che si
chiamava l'app store es
fate che l'autore sarà l'unico che era
in grado di dire che cosa si poteva bere
l'imperatore e che tipo di combinazione
tra acqua e vino perché allora sapeva
solo mischiato ad acqua si doveva fare
in quella cena quindi era l'unico che
poteva anche descrivere il vino con le
sue parole e gli altri assolutamente
dovevano solo assaggiare e annuire
quindi pensate che neanche l'imperatore
poteva scegliere alla cena che cosa far
bere i suoi commensali
ovviamente la evoluta la figura della
love stories è il tempo del medioevo e
del rinascimento è diventata quella del
cocchiere e da una figura talmente
superiore rispetto a tutte le altre che
addirittura c'era un decalogo che ci ha
rinvenuto pochi anni fa in cui si
descrivono tutte le caratteristiche che
deve avere un cocchiere copiare deve
essere giovane deve essere di
bell'aspetto di bei modi e allegro
ora qualcuno nell'associazione ice dei
sommelier oggi potrebbe ridire su alcuni
di queste di questi aspetti però quello
che era importante che allora come oggi
è una figura molto distante rispetto a
tutte le altre perché era l'unica che
poteva usare anche il lessico che la
seconda componente particolare del vino
un lessico tutto particolare che non ha
a che fare con il desco che usiamo tutti
i giorni in slide c'era come c'è più ma
c'erano alcuni esempi per far ben capire
qual è il lessico che oggi usiamo per il
vino e non si usa in altri modi esempio
è tannico il tannino che noi chiediamo
ai nostri figli di 5 anni che cos'è il
tannino credo che nessuno abbia la
minima idea di che cosa stiamo parlando
forse si immagina degli insetti era
qualcosa di strano ma sicuramente non
pensa all'effetto carciofo per dirla in
maniera molto terra terra che l'effetto
che danno i tannini ci sono invece altre
parole che noi usiamo normalmente tipo
caldo che nel mondo del vino ha
totalmente significato diversa quindi
poi non su mediavideo scrivo un vino
caldo non bisogna pensare a vin brulè ma
bisogna pensare è un vino molto alcolico
ecco di queste esempio ce ne sono
veramente tanti e rendono il mondo del
vino mondo difficile da descrivere con
le parole di tutti i giorni
un terzo aspetto particolare diciamo del
vino
è che non sa non ci sono brand
riconosciuti che aiutano il consumatore
normale come tutti noi a scegliere il
prossimo video già al tempo dei romani
c'era 91 vitigni diversi ed avevano
scoperto da poco ad oggi in italia siamo
quelli che ne hanno di più come spesso
accade e siamo a 250 state che questo
numero che già alto di suo deve essere
combinato con il numero di cantine che
soci sono oggi in italia abbiamo 250
mila cantine che producono vino pensate
che in francia che il secondo siamo più
alto al mondo e hanno 80 mila se
pensiamo che ogni cantina lavora al vino
in maniera lo stesso viti in maniera
diversa perché un processo diverso
perché è attualmente in una zona magari
più caldo più fredda
abbiamo un numero infinito praticamente
di combinazioni in un mondo dove i brand
praticamente non esistono sono molto
difficili da da riconoscersi
non esistono per esempio brand
totalmente internazionali cioè una
cantina famoso in italia difficile che
venga proprio riconosciuta tanto in casa
in australia con la cantina migliore
cangiano australiano in francia non è
proprio tanto riconosciuta mentre ci
sono in altissimi tantissime altre
industrie tutti altri brand vengono
riconosciuti praticamente a livello
mondiale
questo che cosa implica la nostra vita
di tutti i giorni che di un difficile
capire e farsi delle associazioni tra un
brand che riconosciamo di alta qualità
trovare delle qualità di buone o cattive
in un certo vin e provare a seguirle man
mano più il suo brand
un altro aspetto diciamo che non
facilita la comprensione del prodotto
qual è quello che sappiamo tutti dire ci
piace che non ci piace in realtà poco
della vera complessità che non riusciamo
a scomporre in elementi primari e capire
qual è l'elemento che ci è piaciuto e
qual è l'elemento che non ci è piaciuto
pensiamo ad esempio
diciamo che viene dal mondo del cibo un
piatto di pasta al sugo tutti sappiamo
dire inizialmente se ci è piaciuto non
ci è piaciuto però riusciamo a fare
anche il passo successivo che è mi è
piaciuto perché era giusta era salata
giusta era cotta giusta e magari c'era
il quel tocco di basilico
veniva dal campo ed era profumato quindi
mi ricordo che quelli sono gli elementi
che mi sono piaciuti e la prossima volta
riesca a fare un passaggio di
pastasciutta che sia buono per come
intendo io
nel vino questo invece non è possibile
perché non riusciamo a vere e proprie di
questa tv e sviluppate per scomporre il
prodotto vino riuscire a capire
esattamente cosa ci è piaciuta e quindi
ricercarlo man mano nelle successive
quindi raccontato un po qual è il
problema del vino oggi quanto è
complesso e quindi come facciamo diciamo
a raggiungerlo a prenderlo finalmente
quindi a farlo diventare più terra terra
più raggiungibile più democratico e se
vogliamo ci sono tre trend che stanno
impattando tutto il tantissimi settori e
che piano piano andranno a impattare
anche vino anzi sono convinto che il
vino cambierà sta già cambiando e
cambierà profondamente
grazie a questi tre trend il primo
innanzitutto è quello della
personalizzazione cosa significa
significa che ognuno di noi può avere
nel nostro caso il vino adatto a se
stessi ha cambiato tanti settori per
esempio ha cambiato anche il settore
della della sartoria la satira nel
settore che stavano andando a scemare
c'era sempre meno gente che riusciva a
farsi un abito su misura perché perché i
sardi era sempre una sempre di più una
una professione in decadimento sempre
meno giovani vogliono farla invece
grazie alla tecnologia una startup
riuscita a trovare un modo per far su
misura
gli abiti anche a distanza e grazie
allora grazie ad altre startup quindi il
fatto di avere abiti su misura e
cresciuto sempre di più negli ultimi
cinque anni nel vino questo cosa implica
io credo molto nella personalizzazione
della customizzazione dell'offerta per
il signore tende significa che io che ha
veramente tanto che era appunto creato
una start up per cercare di aiutare
tutti gli utenti a trovare il mondiale
per loro ognuno di noi come lettore dei
gusti diversi
quindi lo stesso vino può piacere
tantissimo me tema non piacere
assolutamente della persona dice ancora
e questo indipendentemente che sia buono
o cattivo
quindi la start up e si propone
l'obiettivo di proprio a cercare di
capire e di consigliare in qualsiasi
situazione di cibo e di di gruppo di
utenti eccetera eccetera
il vino giusto per quell'occasione ii la
seconda diciamo seconda ondata di trend
che sta cambiando tanti settore quello
del cern queen della condivisione cosa è
cosa significa ovviamente se pensiamo lo
sharing pensiamo a due esempi su tutti
gli altri che sono airbnb e huber che
ormai sono strozzati da tutti ovviamente
loro che cosa hanno adesso fossi lo
hanno reso possibile oggetti o prodotti
che prima erano difficilmente
raggiungibili dalle persone normali in
particolare spendiamo airbnb una villa
un attico di proprietaria di privati
adesso è diventato raggiungibile anche
da una persona che appunto non possiede
quella villa e può avere l'esperienza di
provare restarci nel video che cos'era
che ciò implica questo implica che per
esempio si sono sempre più start up che
cercano di unire utenti diversi che
hanno pagare una bottiglia all ora
vogliono comprare ma non se lo possono
permettere priva del costo grosso e
quindi cercano di unire la cassa
pensione far sì che si incontrano che
possono gioire godere sono della della
bevuta tutti insieme
un altro elemento diciamo di sharing che
sta aiutando molto sempre per il tema di
avvicinamento è quello della delle
cantine e quindi molto spesso diciamo è
più in america un problema molto
americano nelle grosse città si
ripresentino appartamenti più piccoli
venti metri 30 metri quadri senza la
possibilità di avere una cantina quindi
senza possibilità di poter mettersi da
parte
il video di verres solo dopo 15 delle
startup che stanno cercando di fare
sharing di cantine e quindi quando si
hanno spaziale hubble si è disponibili
si possono chiamare questo del vino e lo
metto in un'altra cantina e poi ci si fa
lo scambio quando se ne ha bisogno
terzo e ultimo trend
che sta impattando molto è impatterà il
mondo del vino è quello della
digitalizzazione dell'esperienza cosa
significa è quella della
virtualizzazione questo faccio un
esempio perché si capisce di più il
mondo dell'architettura era molto molto
statico cioè se venivano fatti i disegni
sulla su carta poi su quando sono
arrivati i pc sono stati fatti sui pc
però era difficile per una persona non
esperta immedesimarsi nella casa che si
era stata progettata anche quando anche
quando c'era lo spazio disponibile ci si
poteva entrare la difficile immaginare
da carta poi la realtà bene grazie ad
altre di quest'oggi è più possibile
quindi l'utente si può immedesimare può
entrare addirittura nella casa del
futuro vedere come le architetture
progettate a capire se gli spazi vi
piacciono quali proprio pezzo di
allargamento del peso di blur quali ci
piace di meno è la stessa cosa sta
accadendo nel vino cioè ci sono sempre
più start up che avrà possibilità le
cantine di far vivere l'esperienza della
cantina anche a persone che non ci sono
mai state come potendo caricare school
su questo sito appunto la loro giro
virtuale della cantina con la loro
storia con il loro modo di produzione
con le particolarità col fatto che
magari loro la prendono si raccolgono
solo la luce della luna perché gli dà
tutto un gusto diverso eccetera eccetera
questi sono tutti elementi fondamentali
perché perché il wiener alta è un po
come un prodotto artistico cioè non è
immaginato un quadro astratto non
riusciamo a capire perché ci riusciamo a
dire se ci piacciono ma riusciamo a
capirlo fino in fondo fin quando non c'è
un esperto che ci guida capire quali
sono le particolarità come è stato fatto
quale l'accostamento pensate che ci farà
cogliere appieno tutta la bellezza
comunque tutto il pensiero che ci sta
dietro quadro quindi sto dicendo con la
parte di virtualizzazione grazie al
fatto che le cantine possano mettere
esperienza online possono far sì che
l'utente viva questa esperienza possa
avere un'esperienza migliore del vino e
di quello che sta provando
un problema appunto che avevo raccontato
anche quello del lessico per esempio sul
lessico è già un po più complesso
si sa che cosa stiamo facendo di fare
noi ne abbiamo le nostre gustazione
abbiamo dotato tutti i partecipanti
nella campanella banalissima però questa
campanella deve essere suonata ogni
qualvolta la sommelier parla in maniera
molto strana c'è quando parla maniera
tecnica di scampanella esami è costretto
a ripetere lo stesso concetto tecnico in
maniera molto semplice vi assicuro che
funziona nel senso che quando uno dice
panino e non lo capiamo
si deve inventare un modo per farlo si
deve dire avvolgente ma raiuno capisce
avvolgente son vino cosa significa lo
deve ripetere in modo che anche le
persone normali possono capire che cosa
vi vuole dire in termini tecnici
ora io vi ho descritto questo quello di
cui io credo e dove standard e quella
diciamo che la nostra di
concretizzazione secondo me è il nostro
frank abagnale ci siamo vicini veramente
a prenderlo perché il vino sta sempre
diventando più un prodotto alla portata
però se volete anche voi capire se ho
ragione o meno cioè quanto voi vedete
vicino questo fatto è che tutti noi
possiamo godere appieno
vi invito a venire la degustazione che
ci sarà appunto alla fine dell'era del
ted vedere di vostro sogno di vostra
prima o se vi piacciono e se quello che
stiamo lavorando per rendere questo
prodotto più vicino possibile funziona o
meno
grazie
[Applauso]